Yes, these are Bluetooth.
They work with Android, they work with iPhone.
I just connected them to my boyfriend's phone.
He has Android. I connected them to my phone.
I have iPhone. They connected to, like,
a really older generation.
My daughter's old, old,
old iPhone. I genuinely like these.
I'm happy to have them. They don't pinch my hair.
They don't do any of the things that other headphones do.
They don't, like,
squeeze my head. Sometimes you put them on and there's.
It's like they're trying to crush your head slowly,
so after enough time, it fucking hurts.
They don't do any of that shit,
so I do really, really like them.
They move really smooth and easy to, like,
fold them up and shit.
It's really easy to see the left and right.
I know that sounds stupid,
but it matters when you're listening to music and stuff,
so it's really easy to know which one's left and right.
I don't know. I like them.
They're awesome. They work for everything.
And they do come with the connections too,
so if the Bluetooth isn't working or.
Or if you just like having them wired,
it comes with the regular AC Jack to connect them.